[Music]
if the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying when i get my new car
i get my new house i get my new
relationship then i'm gonna feel so
great well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen for
them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's no effect of drawing the
experience to you with that way so the
person has to use those tools to get
them into the emotional state for them
to feel like it's already happened now
think about this if you get up from a
creative process and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence you feel a passion for the
moment you will not be looking for your
future because you'll feel like it's
already happened it's the moment that we
start feeling those self-limiting
emotions that we feel separation and
then we start looking for it again well
then if you're waiting you're not
creating you're in separation again so
then whatever it takes for you to move
into a state of being and what is a
state of being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
how to activate the power of
manifestation
enjoy
[Music]
if you wake up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person no thing no experience will
stand in the way between you and that
vision and and you will be initiated
in by the universe into wealth you will
be initiated into health you'll be
initiated into freedom those people all
those people that have healed themselves
of all those different health conditions
they are so humble
and so happy and they feel so great that
they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they they actually
are so happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
uh as they do this work rule number two
is create your reality with gabby
bernstein and then the next question i
have for you is when you're thinking
about manifestation and calling in new
things are some of you manic manifesting
so this is really important
are some of you those folks who are like
i've got the list i've got the vision
board i've said it a thousand times i
told all my friends i want him i know
exactly what he looks like and i feel
like he's with me and we're walking down
the street together holding hands
you know who you are
you know who you are right you know
exactly who you are
look there's nothing wrong with being
clear
there's nothing wrong with being clear
but more importantly i want you to be
clear about how you want to feel and i
want you to just feel it
it's not about having the vision board
that's perfect it's not about having the
most amazing list you can do all that
work you can get clear you can be and if
anyone has a note of vision board it's a
beautiful board where you put all of
your images of what you want and plenty
of people spend a lot of time on that
board but they don't get into the energy
of what it feels like
and so they spend a lot of time with the
list and they spend a lot of time with
the board and they spend a lot of time
talking about it but they don't assume
the energy of what it feels like to be
in that manifestation now
assuming the energy of what it felt like
to pop off all your tops really helped
me call in something that will help me
do it
assuming that energy just brought me
into a state of being you are already
there sister you are already doing this
exactly as you are on your video blogs
in your lectures on twitter and facebook
you are already there and you want more
but you are already there
so acknowledging and accepting that i'm
already in the place that i am even
though i want it to be more i am already
there
so if you want a romantic partner
make sure you have a real hot romance
with yourself
if you want more money
make sure you have a real good
relationship with the money you
currently have
if you want a new job make sure you have
a real good relationship with the job
you have today
everybody get that
people think oh well if i appreciate my
job that i have now then i'll only stay
there no absolutely not if you
appreciate the job that you have now
then you show up to that job with grace
you show up to that job with a good
attitude you show up that job with a
better approach you show up to that job
with more energy that job begins to
thank you that job says wait maybe
there's another job for you that job
then says here you're promoted here's
some more money have a great life
you
create your reality your intentions
create your reality so if you are
constantly in a place of thinking i hate
this i hate this i hate this you are
serving that
everybody's with me now i know you are
so rather than focusing on that manic
manifesting first and foremost get
honest if you are one of them if you are
please raise your hands now manic
manifesters just get honest people
get your hands up
manic manifesto so you're reading the
books you're doing the work you think
you think you think but your energy
what's your energy like scream it to me
what's your energy like
frantic
what was that
when you're saying when got it yes okay
what is your energy saying when your
energy's needy right it's controlling
it's manipulative
it's frightened
it's chaotic
what does that girl look like on a date
so what is your energy doing how is your
manic manifesting affecting your genuine
manifestation
so i want you to get clear about that
and then the next piece here is just to
become super conscious and maybe take
yourself for the next 30 days
where you can use that exercise in my
inkbook where you put the little rubber
band around your wrist and you snap the
rubber band every time you catch
yourself talking about lack or you catch
yourself you know avoiding your finances
or you catch yourself eating the
hamburger or you catch yourself manic
manifesting just check yourself before
you wreck yourself
and sl and snap
your wrist right so take that little
everybody got that
you hear yourself you're in the
conversation with your girlfriend and
you're like oh my god i can't get it i
don't know what's going on the man won't
call me back i can't kill myself oh my
god and then all of a sudden instead of
continuing
snap the rubber band
i say i forgive myself
for my lack mentality i forgive myself
for my fear i choose to see this
differently
that's it
you don't need to figure out what to see
differently you just need to say i
choose to see this differently and you
will be given all you need to see
something differently
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number three is keep your
mind open with rhonda byrne for all of
us you know and
we've been conditioned you know i mean
you were very fortunate because you you
had a
a childhood where
you were
mind was opened and you were opened and
your heart was opened and that's the
biggest biggest thing
is to open yourself to the possibility
that everything isn't the way it appears
to be
and so even if you can just open
yourself to that possibility just for a
moment you can pick up it all the next
day you can take it all with you the
next day that it's all real and
everything that you're seeing but if you
just for a moment open to the
possibility that things might not be the
way that you think they are
then you have the greatest opportunity
to really discover something incredible
how incredible you are rule number four
create a vision board with john assaraf
whenever i want to create anything
whether it's my physical body a home a
car a trip there's a big part of our
brain called the occipital lobe back of
our brain even when light comes in
through our eyes right cells in the back
of our brain activate and an image pops
up in our brain and that image that pops
up into our brain is connected to the
motivational center and the thinking
center part of our brain
so if a negative image pops up we reduce
our motivation and we don't take action
and then we reinforce that pattern but
let's say i have
a an image of something that i really
want something that inspires me
that as soon as i pop up that image in
my brain i actually release dopamine
okay
the reward neurochemical in my brain
that actually creates motivation that's
actually tied to what i call as the
einstein part of the part of the brain
that can actually help you figure out
how to achieve that thing
and so i create
images of what is it that i want to
create for health wealth relations
career business charity fun and
experiences so that i can activate the
reward circuits in my brain the
motivational circuits in my brain the
thinking centers of my brain to help me
figure out how to achieve it but the
other purpose of a vision board is to
give your brain the instruction of this
is the stuff that's important to me that
i want to create do be have or give
right so you know we all have you know
50 000 thoughts a day we all have so
much on the social media whether it's
facebook or instagram or youtube or
clubhouse or whatever all the different
you know stations and channels are and
the people that want to get gather our
attention well why don't we become
better at focusing our attention on what
we want to trade our life for and number
five the last one before some very
special bonus clips is touch your dreams
with ed milette your mind gravitates
towards which it is most familiar with
and so um if you're really familiar with
what you're worried about and what your
problems are and your fears are and that
becomes your dominating thinking i know
you've all heard this but here's the
reason why your mind loves what's
familiar
okay and so if you don't go touch dreams
for example just experience it for a
second for example we would go down once
every eight weeks if i did well in
business we really knocked it out we
could find a deal i had 200 bucks we'd
go to the ritz carlton or some hotel
ocean and for one day oceanfront feel
like what it felt like to valet your car
right walk in the lobby mr milette
welcome back right she'd go get a
massage i'd play a little bit of golf
and just for that day i'd touch the
dream and then maybe we'd do it again in
a month or two and again in a month just
little taste of it my mind began to
begin to become familiar with it and
more crazy i started to kind of trick
myself into thinking i belonged there
because we never end up anywhere we
don't believe we don't belong and then
we're not familiar with so there's these
things you'd like to do in your life
either visually seeing them over and
over again or repeating those images to
yourself that's powerful but a double
whammy is to not only repeat them and
see them but to go to see
there's one thing that's a visual
stimulus in your brain that makes you
want to do something the triple whammies
if you could see it touch it feel it and
smell it if you allow all your senses to
experience something it becomes far more
familiar to your brain and so i'm a
massive
massive advocate of touching a dream in
any form you can get it the best of
which is actually going and experiencing
it short term if you begin to believe
you belong there you're a little bit
better and so i you will not probably
produce many things in your life that
you've not visited either mentally or
literally thousands of times and so if
you want to end up somewhere you better
be visiting them those could be dreams
visions but the most important thing is
if you could actually more powerful if
you go touch them short term massive
difference drive by the neighborhood see
the cars if you want to spend your life
in service for your church or your
community take a day out every month and
actually do it know what it feels like
for an afternoon to feed the homeless or
to do and you begin to love it and feel
it and believe you belong there more and
more chance that you'll be able to do
that full time someday
what you believe about yourself is the
only thing that matters at the end of
the day no matter how much outside
affirmations you get or other people
telling you that you're amazing if you
don't believe in your heart that you are
amazing it won't none of that will last
like you ever gone to an event or you
ever made a video or created something
or you're hanging out with a friend and
they tell you how amazing you are and
that feels good right like the external
affirmations and validation feels great
but then it fades
that stuff doesn't last you don't have
somebody being a cheerleader for you
every day showing up in your bedroom
saying hooray go do this you're amazing
right we don't have that
you have to be that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting
your value as a human being
from other people when they tell you
that you're amazing
you're never going to love your life
you're never going to love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
okay so that's that's a lot of words how
do you actually go off and do it
i think for me it's this is why i
believe that lack of belief is
the world's number one problem
you know i can go and meet somebody and
feel them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they
they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines and systems and schedules to
slowly shift
your belief in yourself forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our
worst enemies it's rough
i just think it's great to be your own
worst critic
i think it's great i think honestly i
think for a lot of people
um we're not hard enough on ourselves
let me let me stick with me for a minute
we're not hard enough on ourselves
because in order to get to where you
want to go you actually need to push
yourself more the problem is why we
can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things
we're very hard on ourselves but because
there's no
self love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like i'm sitting here in a parking lot
these you know those i guess it's kind
of blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on we're barely
hanging on to what we're doing we we can
post all these great things on instagram
or wherever and make it look like we're
enjoying our life but most people are
barely hanging on the people who are
judging you for your life and telling
you that you suck hate their own lives
they are barely hanging on so how do we
get through it well
yes we can be harder on ourselves
but we need to balance that with more
self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great
what you're proud of what you're
grateful for and it has to be consistent
otherwise you'll never get to where you
want to go and when you
love yourself more
that actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because
it's not going to push you over the edge
because you're not tying your self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of i'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when i go to events
a youtube event for example if i'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or youtube related
um
i'm going in thinking
i'm kick ass
and
because i feel that i don't need to say
that
like a lot of times
we feel like we need to say that because
it's it's
masking and insecurity
right it's like those people who uh
we've seen those memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even jay-z like early jay-z you
know he's got all this change and
everything now he's like he doesn't care
you know he's walking on a t-shirt and
some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so
self-confident now that it doesn't
matter now it's actually expression
instead of masculine insecurity
most of us are just masking insecurities
instead of actually being self-confident
and so when i'm going to an event if i'm
talking about youtube i'm walking in
feeling amazing
and i don't need to
i don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and
it's actually the opposite i can go up
and say hey where do i suck
it's my favorite question ask why do i
suck where do i suck can you point it
out if i can find one person to tell me
where i suck at something how my videos
suck my thumbnails suck
do i don't believe that they suck
right
i think they're amazing
but because i think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how i think
it could be better
and so i think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute
number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that i do is i put music on
and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
if they came on you would have to you
would have to move
right it doesn't mean that you're up and
like dancing through the whole house
going crazy in your underwear first
thing in the morning but something that
even if it's just making your head bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head bob
and you'd probably be singing maybe not
out loud but singing under your breath
i'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're
singing out lyrics
that are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on every day first start your day
with music it's the fastest way to
change your state to go from
feeling low and tired and just
wha what day is it what am i doing i
wake up every day like what day is it
what am i doing today yeah it's
but i demand excellence and that that
starts with music because i don't have i
don't want to spend a lot of time trying
to get into the right state of mind i
can command it whenever i want just by
putting on the right song so be in
tension with your music and the lyrics
being positive
two
connect to
the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing i'll do is i'll take
the dogs out and then i'll go for
what i call a believe walk and it's
probably the most important part of my
morning routine is i go for a believe
walk
and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and
i'll go for a walk by myself
with 20 pounds on my back i'll go
wrecking
uh a walk to
tim hortons usually get a coffee
you know this cost two bucks to
something
so
i only had
you know what's the what's the best
money i spend every year well it's the
700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
the coffee every morning and i'm
thinking about what's my intention for
the day and i'm thinking about what i
want to accomplish today and the lives
that i want to serve and the people i
want to help and and what i'm about to
do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone
all the dms and the emails and the texts
and the missed calls and all it's all
other people's agenda for your time that
that is not an intentional life we wake
up like an accident and start falling
into what other people want us to do
today that's not what you need to do and
you need to protect your time
so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own
whether it's 20 minutes or an hour
that's really just a feel thing too i
don't book anything until 10 30 at the
earliest in my calendar
most of my meetings would be eleven
first meeting would be eleven movement
makers and brand lytics i'll start at 10
30
and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
i want to do and so if i want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes i can do that because i'm
thinking because i'm brainstorming
because i'm i'm
going through an idea i treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate that
means it's the same thing
i just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much i like something a little more
active so i go for my belief locks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to
think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel
about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation
and somebody else's
words of affirmation for us to
feel worthy
and flip it to say i am worthy
i am amazing
i can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things your
personality literally yet is made up of
how you think
how you act and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is your personality and your
personality is intimately connected to
your personal reality your life so then
if you want to change your life
your personal reality you got to change
your personality and here we go again
you got to start becoming conscious of
your unconscious thoughts you got to
start noticing how you act how you speak
you got to pay attention to how you're
feeling some people would live in guilt
their whole entire life and don't even
know it's guilt because at least it
feels like them so then when you start
doing that you begin to objectify your
subjective self so
so then
when you begin to make small changes
back to thought a new thought should
lead to a new choice a new choice should
lead to a new behavior a new behavior
should create a new experience and a new
experience should create a new emotion
yes and that new emotion is teaching
your body chemically to understand what
your mind is intellectually understood
now your body is embodying the truth
right so then the new emotion should
inspire new thoughts and that's called
evolution so how do we get stuck
it's really simple
the stronger the emotion you feel from
some event in your life be it a betrayal
or a trauma or whatever yes the more
altered you feel inside of you the more
you pay attention to the cause outside
of you so the brain takes a snapshot
it freezes an image and embosses that
pattern neurologically in the brain
that's called a memory so we create
long-term memories from strong emotional
events okay so is that true i just want
to understand the maybe the larger the
event in terms of its emotion to you the
stronger of a hold it has over you yeah
well the more it's embossed in your
biology so some certain people have a
strong experience in their life and it
catches all of the brain's attention so
now they think
neurologically within the circuits of
the past experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and so how you think and
how you feel creates a state of being
now here's the problem
that if you don't know how to mediate or
control your emotional reaction to that
event
and you keep that refractory period of
chemicals going on for extended periods
of time
so that the event produces a chemical
change and the body needs to return back
to homeostasis or balance but if it
can't then the elongation of that
emotional reaction
for weeks say for days or weeks is
called the mood so you say ed what's
wrong with you i'm in a mood why are you
in a mood well this thing happened to me
five days ago and i'm having one long
emotional reaction so then what you do
is you keep telling the story about it
keep firing and wiring the same circuits
and you keep conditioning the body into
the past so then you wake up in the
morning you look for the emotion
so then now all of a sudden you keep it
lingering for for for weeks or months
that's called the temperament well why
is he so angry i don't know let's ask
him why are you so angry well this thing
happened to me eight months ago i'm
having one long emotional reaction i'm
memorizing my emotions you keep it going
on for years on end that's called a
personality trait so then a person then
is memorizing themselves
by living in the past and so then you
say to them well tell me the story now
the latest research on memory says that
50
of what we talk about in our past isn't
even the truth so we make stuff up about
the past in other words people are
reliving a life that they didn't even
have wow just to reaffirm that they
can't change right
so then what's the significance of this
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy period yes so then
the stronger the emotion that you have
to some problem or condition or person
in your life the more you're paying
attention to them so they captured your
attention so you're giving your power
away
to that person right because they're
capturing your attention so then there's
an energetic connection to every person
everything everything in your past
present reality has your energy
connected to it so now
this is the significance when a person
really decides to be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memory of
the past the hardest part about it is
all of a sudden becoming conscious and
not making the same unconscious choice
so then
if you lower the volume to your
frustration to your hatred to your anger
if you truly knew how to do that if you
lowered the volume to that emotion you
would take your attention off that
person which means you would begin to
break those energetic bonds and now
you're taking your power back yes you're
calling energy back to you we've
measured this and all of a sudden it
builds this bigger electromagnetic
magnetic field around the person's body
that's energy to heal that's energy to
create a new future with right
and then if you didn't want to lower the
volume to the emotion then just take
your attention off the person and every
time you take your attention off the
person if you became conscious of that
you wouldn't feel the emotion now the
body though
has been addicted to that emotion right
because you're using that person to
reaffirm your addiction to hatred or
frustration and if that person died
you'd find another one so then here you
go now so
now you're in a position now where you
begin to lower the volume to that
emotion and the body's going wait a
second you've been you've been doing
this for the last 20 years and all of a
sudden you're just gonna stop hating and
the body says well i've been conditioned
this way and conditioning is based on
the past so when the body feels the the
lack of that emotion just like a drug
addict it says hey you're off schedule
here so now the body starts influencing
the mind to think about experiences that
are embossed in the brain that are based
on that emotion so the emotion now is
causing you to think in the past if we
teach a person then how to trade that
frustration or that hatred for an
elevated emotion and they'll say yeah
but you know it was my ex's fault or i
got betrayed by my partner in business
yeah yeah yeah we know that okay so
let's take your partner in business or
take your ex let's duct tape them put
them in a cannon and shoot them to the
moon now what are you going to do sooner
or later you got to reckon with yourself
and change right so then
teach a person then how to trade that
emotion for an elevated emotion now
trade the emotion for an elevated
emotion right so you're going to give
that up and you're going to practice
feeling gratitude for as an example yes
the person says well i can't feel
gratitude and i say absolutely you can
because you don't practice feeling it
you practice spending most of your time
feeling hatred and frustration so now
it's going to take a little time to
cause that heart of you to bloom or your
heart of yours to bloom once they're
able to feel even the smallest measure
of gratitude where they start feeling
appreciation
thankfulness
gratitude it's emotional signature when
you when you get something
when you're receiving something
when something has happened to you
or when something is happening to you
you say thank you because you're
receiving something so the emotional
signature
of gratitude means the event has already
happened where it's happening to you so
the moment you open your heart and you
feel gratitude well that emotion then is
telling the body that the experience has
already occurred and the thought then
can make it into the body because it's
consistent with the thought so now
you're beginning to program the
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific destiny and you've got to
maintain that modified state of mind and
body your entire day
independent of the conditions in your
outer environment
independent of your body's cravings of
those emotions and habituations and
independent from time and if you can
get ready
because something weird or unusual some
synchronicity some coincidence some
opportunity is going to land in your lap
and you didn't have to go and get it yes
it came to you now you're the vortex of
creation so if you say to me well i was
feeling gratitude but then there was
traffic or my co-worker sent me a
nasty email then i would say oh my god
you mean you're allowing your
environment your outer environment to
control how you feel and think you're
back to the unconscious program that
you're the victim to your life you got
it but when you start producing those
outcomes in your life you're going to
pay attention to what you did inside of
you and you're going to believe more
that you're the creator of your life and
less of the victim of your life let me
explain what happened so this really
interesting concept called ghosts in the
nursery
and so trauma patterns get automated it
because they're not experienced in your
brain they're felt in your nervous
system
and so it's why you can have a pattern
from your past but be completely unaware
that it's running your life right now
because it's stored not in your
conscious thought but in your nervous
system and you feel it in your body
before it even gets into your head and
so from there's this concept called
ghost in the nursery which basically
means there's all kinds of that goes on
when you're little that you may or may
not remember in your mind but your body
remembers it so for example if you had
parents that were just stressed out
and
they come home and they've been busy and
you're sitting there playing on the
floor and there's there's toys
everywhere and mom or dad's reaction to
a mess is to scream
that creates this kind of thing in your
nervous system now you may not remember
that episode that happened on may 17
1972
but your nervous system remembers what
it's like
so fast forward you're now 51 years old
and
you walk in the house and there's a mess
everywhere and even though you have said
i'm not going to bulldoze and yell at
anybody
my
body recognizes the situation
so what do you do you repeat the pattern
you saw
and so what i'm working on right now is
a pattern that is encoded in my nervous
system
i was trying to create a video yes or
two days ago
um for sure the mic for share the mic
now um trying to create a video and i'm
like doing take after take because i
want to get it right
and my daughter comes waltzing into the
room
and was like
how long are you going to be doing this
and i was like
can't you say that i'm working i
literally like screamed at her and she
looked at me louis
and she goes
you have a real problem wow how's your
daughter
20.
and i said i calmly said you're right i
do
when i get interrupted
i
lose control of the response and i'm
working so
hard and the way that you and i'm not
clearly not mastering this yet
but the way that you do it is as you
feel it rise up
you have to you know you can use the
five second rule 54321 you can use just
take a quick breath
you can notice the pattern and you've
got to create a pause between the
emotion rising up and the reaction that
gets automated and for many people the
reaction loss is to run away
it's to leave the room it's to avoid the
confrontation the it was just easy you
know oh hold on let me let the clock go
even though you you hate being
interrupted by anything this is a great
interview i did like i didn't do i
didn't do the bulldozer i was i was calm
because i wasn't a human being i'm only
mean to human beings
um i know like i a lot of people run
away they avoid conflict they say it's
just easier
but if running away and avoiding
conflict
continues to create a pattern where you
feel invisible and your boundaries are
trumped on that's a pattern and you know
here's the other thing about patterns
running away
and being quiet might have saved you
when you were little
because if you were quiet and out of the
room you didn't get hit you didn't get
yelled at you were out of harm's way
so when you were little it was a genius
pattern because it protected you but the
issue for adults is that again we walk
around
with the patterns that we created when
we were eight years old in different
situations and we are in now and now we
are
completely a robot to these patterns
becoming a monk was my biggest dream
growing up from that time period that i
made the monk 18 which we spoke about
the last time i was here and so that
became like my identity from 18 to 22
and then 22 to 25 when i lived as a monk
so it's like that's been my identity for
seven years at least in my heart in my
head
and so when you get to the end of a
self-awareness journey which is actually
the beginning but you get to the end of
it because you're like oh i'm not a monk
anymore and i'm sure you've gone through
similar things like oh i'm not a ceo
anymore of this right of a business that
does this or someone else may go through
i'm not married anymore i'm now divorced
i am now not single anymore or i'm not
alone i've got kids right it's like we
all go through these identity
transitions in our life
and to me
going from being a monk to not being a
monk was the hardest transition that i'd
been through at that time and the
question that i'm having is
i'm having reflections on who i truly am
and what my skills are what my strengths
are what my passion is what my
compassion is and i'm saying i want to
share all of this in like a cool way
through entertainment and i love movies
and that's what the book's full of like
pop culture references and it's it's a
it's it's who i am and what i love about
myself
and then i'm going but this doesn't
align with what monk life is meant to be
in a sacred way
and that is like looking in the mirror
and going oh like i'm not comfortable
with that so when i share that with my
teacher and we're having this discussion
he's his advice and i think this is the
part that you're referring to he says to
me that
there's
students that come to university
and then they become professors
and there are students that come to the
university and then they go out and
become entrepreneurs
or go out and work and he says which do
you think are better
i'm like i mean neither really like i
can't really choose what makes someone
better
and he was just like
that's the point you you came here
some people stay at the monastery and go
on to become senior monks and teachers
and some people will go out and do what
they do outside and he goes but neither
is better and it was the simplest advice
it's one of those pieces of advice that
it's all about the person that says it
and not necessarily what you're hearing
but for me it just clarified the
judgment i had
the
attachment i had
that i could only be happy and
purposeful in this way
and that's really what we're all
struggling with that currently we all
have a projector screen up here that
goes this is what life's meant to look
like for it to be happy and then down
here we have the reality version of what
life actually looks like and we go oh no
they don't match that doesn't match
that's not working that means i'm going
down the wrong direction
the funny thing is the version you have
doesn't exist at all it's just an
imagination it's it's virtual reality
and the reality that you're experiencing
could actually be getting you closer to
that goal than you even think but you
just don't want to go down that path
because it doesn't look like the one you
imagine and that's where i was at
i was having to go down a path that i
didn't imagine looked like success but
then the question is well what does
success look like then and it definitely
doesn't look like the version in your
head
so to me i started to realize and i
genuinely believe this
and your affirmation is very useful to
me the three years of my life
living as a monk were like being at
monk's school
and the last seven years have been the
exam
and everything in this book is stuff
that i've tried and tested in the last
seven years i learned it amongst school
but i tested it in in reality
and i'm only sharing what in the last
seven years it's perfectly worked for me
to feel like i'm exactly where i need to
be
that doesn't mean i don't have off days
that doesn't mean that i'm happy all the
time it doesn't mean that i don't get
angry it doesn't mean that i don't get
upset but i'm going in the direction
that i want to be going in several years
ago
i went to see a friend of mine
and he is considered by all means one of
the leading experts in the world on eeg
and brainwave frequencies and really
understanding
how our brain waves affect
how we feel and what we think about and
i went to this biocybernaut institute to
be able to recognize one thing
number one was that my thoughts happened
randomly as a result of all of the years
of
learning experiencing listening to my
parents my teachers my brother my sister
and myself and as a result of that i
developed these neural patterns or brain
patterns that created these automatic
thoughts
some of them are positive some of them
were negative
however what i learned at the
biocybernaut institute was that i could
control
my thoughts
now listen to me for just a moment if
you think about this
are you your brain
well the answer is no your brain is an
organ however your brain has billions of
cells and those cells connect and talk
to each other
every time you have a positive thought
you reinforce that thought pattern every
time you have a negative thought you
reinforce that thought pattern even
faster now the reason that your brain
does this is because it wants to protect
you from any real or imagined danger and
so a negative thought
is something that happens in the brain
that when it happens it reinforces
itself way faster than the positive
thought so one of the things that you
can do
is this number one
is give your brain a command since
you're not your brain you can do this
and science has proven this you can give
your brain a command to let you become
aware
of when you're having a negative thought
or even a negative emotion
so the first spot or the first part that
you need to take control over is the
awareness part of what's happening
within you
then the next part is to recognize and
realize that you don't have to play into
a negative thought you don't have to let
it control you you can actually observe
your negative thought you can observe
even a negative emotion or an unpleasant
emotion and you can surrender to it and
what does that mean surrender doesn't
mean give up
surrender just means allow it to happen
without getting emotionally attached to
it
now if you become aware of an emotional
or mental thought that you have that's
negative and you surrender to it and
just allow it to flow by
you can use the word next
in order to give your brain a command to
move on to the next thought or to move
on to the next emotion and so as you're
aware of it as you surrender to it and
use the word next what i want you to do
next is refocus
your brain on what you want
the thought to be and the emotion to be
so you can choose a polar opposite
thought
that will really empower you
to have the right emotion and more
importantly will empower you to take
action around the new thought and
emotion so again the three steps are
become aware of your thoughts and your
emotions
surrender to them by allowing them to
happen let them go by releasing them by
saying the word next and then refocus
your thoughts on what you want to
achieve what you want to take action on
and that way you'll start to be in
control of your thoughts your emotions
which will then drive the behaviors that
you want in order to achieve the goals
that are most important to you the voice
within us that believes that we are not
allowed to be happy
our card today is speaking to that
i believe i'm worthy of feeling good i
believe i am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice but it's
actually far from our reality
because many of us have been brought up
with the belief system that we have to
suffer to succeed that we have to feel
pain to have purpose that we have to
have struggles in order to feel a sense
of serenity in our life
that is all quite backwards
it's when we feel good that we actually
attract more of what we want into our
life but we have to undo the belief
system that says who am i to feel good
who am i to feel great who am i to be
happy
that belief system is an ingrained
belief system that can be cultural that
can be something that we learned from
our upbringing it can be something that
we have picked up from this difficult
experience that we're going through
right now with covid when we witness
people suffering we think well how dare
i be happy i would say to you how dare
you not be happy it's your happiness
it's the collective happiness it's the
group collective happiness that raises
the energetic frequency of the world if
we those of us who have moments of
happiness and grace and joy and success
and we don't celebrate them we are doing
the world a disservice we are shutting
down the light we are bringing down the
vibration so we have to when we feel
good we have to reach for more when we
feel good we have to recognize that that
good feeling emotion has momentum it has
power it elevates our children it
elevates our family members it elevates
our friends it elevates strangers on the
street it is your divine duty here on
earth to bring forth that greatness that
goodness that light so when you hear
that voice that says to you you are not
worthy of feeling good i want you to
hear my voice come through and say to
you
who are you not to feel good
this is your divine purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me
we are more comfortable being
uncomfortable then we are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a
solution-happiness-oriented mindset so
when that happens the next time you
notice that you're feeling good and all
is well and all of a sudden you're like
but i wasn't nice enough to that person
or my co-workers aren't in a good place
or i didn't do that right i want you to
speak back to that voice i want you to
say thank you for sharing but i choose
happiness instead thank you for sharing
but i don't believe that voice anymore
thank you for sharing but i'm choosing
this moment give yourself permission in
the moment to speak back to the
fault-finding voice and start to claim
the greatness of who you are that is a
pattern because you've lived your life
in a habitual pattern of seeking
problems and finding fault now we have
to redirect and create a new habit and
pattern of grounding you in the truth of
who you are which is happiness joy peace
and
grace sharing that happiness joy and
peace with so much grace
that's what you're here for the
beautiful thing about monk life is half
the day is self and half the day is
service that's how you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like putting
on mental emotional and physical armor
like that's what a morning routine is
our days are tiring our days are busy
our days are draining well guess what if
you didn't put your armor on in the
morning
and you're going out to battle
how many knives are going to cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you
how many wounds are you going to come
home with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded
i come back home feeling wounded
sometimes but guess what if you put your
armor on in the morning a warrior would
never go out onto a battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes your
relationships can be damaging sometimes
your friendships can be toxic sometimes
so we are
warriors in one sense
and so without wearing that so for me a
morning routine is putting on emotional
armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day and that way even if you
do get pierced or you do get popped or
you do get cut
you're protected
and i know that when my morning routine
is at its best i feel protected
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened i feel weak
and so for me the morning routine as i
get strategic about it there's two
principles you have to know
location has energy
and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day that place now
holds that energy
and this is huge like it's it's just so
big and i'm grateful for that reaction
because people don't realize how how
powerful this is like when i meditated
in temples that were 5 000 years old in
south india
it was easier to meditate because people
have been meditating there for thousands
of years
and so when you find a space in your
home and even if you've got like i lived
in a 500 square foot apartment in new
york four years ago
and i just had a tiny corner which i
dedicated to my sacred practices so if
you you don't have to have a big home to
do this you don't have to be wealthy to
do this you can find just a corner in
your home that you dedicate your
meditation space or your reflection
space so first thing location has energy
second thing
time has memory
and this is something that people
underestimate when you do something at
the same time every day
you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle to work out at different times
every day it's why we struggle like why
do we feel hungry at the same time every
day generally we feel hungry at the same
time most people if you've got a
regulated diet you'll feel hungry you'll
feel tired at the same time every day
you will look towards that coke can or
that sugar or that chocolate bar at the
same time every day
and so when you're meditating at the
same time if you're exercising at the
same time so what i recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and i call it
time it's about making time in the day
okay so time stands for t-i-m-e
t stands for thankfulness
there needs to be
even if it's five minutes five minutes
of thankfulness of gratitude every
single morning and that has to be
gratitude that's specific it can't be
gratitude that's generic so generic
gratitude is something that anyone could
be grateful for oh i'm grateful for the
sky i'm grateful for air i'm grateful
for water that's cool but it's generic
gratitude
specific gratitude is i'm grateful for
the fact that i have someone calling me
this morning i'm grateful for the fact
that i can still call my parents i'm
grateful for the fact that i have this
person in my business who is having such
an impact i'm grateful you know it's
specificity yeah so thankfulness second
one is insight i think this is one thing
that a lot of people are missing which i
recommend people listening to you it's
like
podcasts books and and make it easier
for yourself if you get this book leave
it open
on your bedside table
leave it open on your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table i
guarantee you you will read more and
what you read will speak to you and i
think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open and
you'll just flick to a chapter randomly
and you pick up one line it will impact
you and it'll speak to you so insight
you need insight every day m is
meditation and i believe meditation is
different for different people as monks
we did walking meditations we did beach
meditations we did visualizations we did
breath work find your meditation
practice i give a ton in the book and
fourth obviously exercise which you can
speak to even more than i can i exercise
to keep fit you look amazing too though
but it's an exercise everyone needs to
find five minutes a day 15 minutes a day
of exercise when i was small mom i was
also really undersized so it's probably
one reason i lift weights i was always
the every baseball picture on the kid
holding the sign in the front right so i
was small and skinny they used to tease
me eddie spaghetti you know and i'd get
bullied at school and i never retaliated
so i had that mixed with shyness mixed
with chaos in my home which many people
can relate to
and i got to tell you that the shift for
me sports was good for me because it
gave me an out that i finally found
something that i was pretty good at
i think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when i was a little boy when i got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size i was fast
i was the fast kid right i always wanted
to be fast kid and i got confidence in
baseball doing that when i got into
business i said you know you're intense
when someone points out a gift about you
that you also kind of intuitively know
to be true they're linked to them you're
intense you're passionate you won't get
out worked you're relentless i went i am
those things and when someone linked
those gifts to me winning now i believed
i could win that's the other way to
change identity is when someone can link
your giftedness to the victory you'll
believe it not like you're great that's
general that's [ __ ] but it's
something you know specific like for you
right now
you wouldn't brag about there's a few
things you know you know what i am good
at these things right i've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer you have
this general
you you don't need to be the smartest
person in the room because you probably
are most of the time and so there's a
confidence no there's a confidence that
allows you to be present when you
interview me and just listen that's
different than anyone who's interviewed
me before and so that's a natural
giftedness for you which is why there's
a part of you that kind of knows i am
pretty you wouldn't say it but i am
pretty good at this this is a good
program and so the way we change our
identity the way i changed mine was by
getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and then using them
in my career using them in my life that
shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was i suck i'm shy
i'm small i have a screwed up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the weight is these are some gifts
god gave me or the universe gave me or
that at least i know i have and i can
spend my life using these gifts now i've
got hope now my identity's changing now
my life takes a different direction what
is fear
is fear something that you should fear
no
i want you to imagine is you're driving
down the street in your car
and a light pops up on the dashboard
a light pops up um
have you ever taken a hammer and hit the
light because you don't like the light
of course not that would be silly right
what if the light on the dashboard was
just a signal maybe you're low on tire
air uh air pressure maybe uh you're
missing air or water in your windshield
wiper maybe the back trunk door is open
isn't
the signal in your car
just for you to be aware that maybe
something is wrong or something needs
attention
is it possible that if we stop thinking
of fear as the enemy fear is one of your
biggest friends why well when you
understand how did this organism
okay develop and how
does it keep us alive
it pays attention to things okay in your
external world triggers from your
external word that could cause your
death or destruction it causes you to do
what when there is a potential
that threat
predator or threat at the door it lights
up the fear signal sends cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine into your
bloodstream so you either know how to
fight it you run away or you freeze
hoping that the predator will go away
so when your brain
every brain
gets this signal
that there is a threat
at the door
it sends a signal
in the form of a neurochemical that you
feel
now if somebody
feels this threat in their body but they
don't know how to manage the emotion we
call fear
let's say there's a fear that you have a
failure and what it might mean to your
family what what about a fear of losing
money and not having enough to pay the
rent the mortgage or for retirement what
if there's a fear of trying something
and then it not working out and you're
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed or
rejected or judged oh my god if you
judge me then you're gonna reinforce my
low self-esteem of myself and then all i
said who am i
you understand what's happening in the
circuits i'm just describing
so when our brain has
this fierce circuit activated do you
think the fear circuit causes you to go
oh hey let's take action anyway
or do you think it goes hi alert hi
alert hi alert be aware what's going on
what if you fail what if you succeed
with succeed and fail
whenever that circuit is triggered
motivational circuit shuts down whenever
that circuit is activated your thinking
circuit shuts down all the blood flow
goes into a part of your brain to help
you do what possibly run away protect
yourself
it's a protection mechanism but here is
what i want you to remember
this automatic trigger and circuit has
been evolving for millions of years but
your specific experiences since you were
born in the modeling experiential
and the
um and the imprinting years caused you
to have
beliefs
about things some empower you some
disempowered let me give you an example
okay let me give you an example
when i say the word
or let me give you a different uh same
example with just a little different
story
if i say to you that i'd like to take a
big snake about five feet long and let
it slither across your arm and around
your neck and it's a python
how many of you go oh wow that would be
great
versus how many of you are going oh my
god let me run away get get it off of me
just just think of a snake slithering on
you and curling itself around your neck
how many of you are like run
versus oh my god that would be great can
you take a picture of me with it so i
put on social media
so
is it really the snake
that is the threat
or is it
your concept in your brain the meaning
that you have associated with a snake
that is activating for some of you the
reward center
and for others the fear center same
stake stain stimuli there isn't even a
snake here i just add you think about it
right and it triggered that fear circuit
for some rewards circuit for others so
it's never about the thing so when we
have fear
of being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
judged uh fear of disappointing
ourselves fear of failing if you're
succeeding there's 50 different types of
fears we automatically trigger
the circuit
that does what stops our action taking
everyone has unresolved areas where they
are out of alignment due to their
upbringing their
belief systems from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted
so some people might be health some
people it might be sex some people it
might be money some people it might be
their worth some people might be all of
the above whatever we've all got it
we've all got an area or many where we
are misaligned with
the feeling of love and abundance and
and grace that's normal that's natural
that's where it's at and just because
you fall into those belief systems and
feel into that frequency from time to
time doesn't mean that you are doing
anything wrong it's that you are your
awareness of it is actually major okay
so
the undoing of the lac mentality is a
journey of
clearing
the belief systems from a experiential
time in your life right that happens
once again through books like the
universe has your back so fantastic that
you're doing that transform fear to
faith
excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural pathways
from the experiences that we've had as
children particularly young childhood
experiences but the good news is thanks
to neural plasticity our brain actually
can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our ptsd can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new behavior so
one thing that you can do simply in this
moment is to notice when you are in that
lac mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again and this is a method
i've shared over and over and over again
on this show the choose again method
because
yes i could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy which everyone i hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but
what you can do for yourself you're here
for self-help you're here for gabby to
tell me how i can serve myself
you can be in the proactive development
of new thought patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel
step two forgive yourself for having the
thought it's very simple up there's my
childhood story there's my parents lack
story again up there it is again all
right i forgive myself it just showed up
again because that forgiveness will
dissolve that guilt and tension and fear
that you're manifesting it all that crap
right
third step
choose the next best feeling thought
choose the thought of you know what i
just forgave myself for that thought so
i'm dissolving it in this moment
i actually am listening to the universe
has your back and it's so supportive
then i can actually go and listen to
super attractor so you can go from
thought to thought to thought to reach
for the next best feeling thought so
your willingness to face this lack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you
right and especially if you're feeling
afraid that you're manifesting things
because you're having the thoughts then
just forgive the thoughts because or
forgive yourself for having the thought
because the moment that you say oh i
forgive myself for that thought or i
forgive that thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized i am not that
thought it's just a thought that i keep
thinking i am not that belief it's just
a thought that i keep thinking you have
no idea what you're capable of you have
no idea you have no idea the person you
could be to think you could accomplish
the things you can do the people you can
serve you've no idea that's why i don't
like 10-year goals 10-year goals think
about who you used to be 10 years ago
you know could that person accurately
with any with any degree of certainty
predict where you could be right now no
like if you're growing and you're
learning you're improving and you're
expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're gonna be
in one year let alone five years or ten
years you have no idea what you're
capable of
and so it comes down to questioning
everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of crew
you should go into right we're told we
should do all these things you're told
you're like who you know nobody ever
thought to ask us what we want for our
lives and you may not even know and
that's okay like you may know where you
want to go next but you may not
ultimately know the final destination
it's awesome
you know i think if you know the final
destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do i want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what i'm
chasing down every day
do i know where i'm going to be in a
year nope
am i still making videos probably but
who knows i question everything i wanna
i want people to believe themselves more
what's the best way to do that right now
it's through youtube
but i think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan
and then they end
up playing small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and plans but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal
quite often you need to jump off that
goal two years in because something
better has come along that actually
better serves who you are right now
because the goal you set was for who you
used to be
you know have you felt that and so i'm
here at a genius network and this is a
group of super successful entrepreneurs
that meets once a month and masterminds
and talk about their business and
pay a lot of money to be a part of
something like this
and
every time i'm around people who are who
are having a high degree of success
i always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you
basically share what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn
i just want people to ask me questions
because
your biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
knew what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have
is a problem you know the problem you
think you have yes very much is a
problem but there's a deeper problem
underneath it that you're missing
that i'm missing
so this is where questioning everything
becomes important my default has become
instead of pretending like i know
everything and i know all my problems
that i don't know anything and ask me
questions
and in the process
of asking me questions and learning
about me maybe you come with some
insight that i've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
um
giving advice you know so i'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure or nine figure business
and people here have sold their
businesses
uh
for nine figures
crazy
awesome
and so
they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and
breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question
and having them trying to fit into my
box i'd rather fit into theirs
because in trying to understand how they
process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and i'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that i don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it
right because we're we hold on to our
identity like no no that's not gonna
work for me
you know even oh i gotta be
i am allergic to bees
maybe i should question that
i don't feel like questioning that today
though
do not want to get stung by a bee i once
got stung by a bee and uh
only time in my life i've been sung by a
bee and it i was on the floor and my my
back just
swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway
maybe question everything except these
things how about that
uh there's been times when people have
given me advice and it made sense and it
really fit
and sometimes when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what i'll default in my head the same is
this is either nothing like the person
didn't read me correctly or it's the
whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool i should go and
do that cool they they they met you
where you were at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't
feel right
and
it could be that it just wasn't a fit
and they're giving you the wrong advice
or
you're so blind and this is what
gets me excited is maybe i'm so blind
maybe i believe my story so much
that the thing that you're talking about
is actually the whole thing like it's
all i should care about
because figuring out how to solve that
because i'm so tied to my own story that
i'm not questioning enough and coming
back to the b spot hopefully it's gone
i'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock
so a quick story on this i did a life
coaching session with gary vee's lead
coach beth hendell and at first i was
shocked i didn't know i didn't know
garyvee had a life coach and so i was
very excited to talk to her and
just like i've been explaining this
video i went through her process like
how do you ask questions what do you
want to know about me i don't want it to
be if this is a coaching session just
treat me as a treat me as a client treat
me as somebody who you're gonna coach
what do you need to know from my story
and how i act and i'm gonna i'm gonna be
as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying um was
great
but my single biggest insight and
takeaway was this and i'm practicing
this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically i've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like i want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so i
have the belief in the plan and i wake
up every day and i just do the plan
because i believe in the plan
i have some days where i don't believe
in a plan anymore like will this plan
help get me anywhere is this plan still
working like it's not working anymore
and that leads to
some anxiety for me because i believe in
the plan and when the plan doesn't work
what happens
and so what i'll end up doing is making
a new plan so i have a plan i believe in
a plan until i don't believe in it
anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
the following so when creating a new
plan then i have certainty in the plan
again and i'm fine and i'm rocking and
rolling but
there are some days
there are some days when i can't come up
with a new plan the plan i have i don't
believe in anymore and i'm rocking my
brain to come up with a new plan and i
can't come up with a new plan
if i'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and i can't come up with a
new plan that's a really
uh stress-inducing anxiety field place
to be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and i can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
well what i would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me
you know what you know what happened
great things happen to you
and i would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because i didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be a downward spiral
like if i believe in the plan and that
the plan is not working and i can't come
up with a new plan
then i don't know what to do with my
life and that would create a downward
spiral i've never gone anywhere close to
depression or suicide but that would
lead to some dark that could lead to
some dark places
and so the way that i come out of it is
just say great things will happen to me
great things happen to me they already
they always happen to me weird things
happen to me and i'll figure this out
and that gives me the comfort
to move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that i will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing
of great things happen to you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default state and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it
to the point where great things happen
to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self
and
i really felt that i don't know how to
do it
but even in questioning how do i do it
i just have to believe that great things
happen to me
so
a big part of my routine now is is i
don't know how many times i'll i'll say
that to myself feel that
way things happen to me i'm gonna put it
as my new cell phone background um it's
a it's a constant reminder even making
these videos another reinforcement of it
um when people ask me what my goals are
there's been these exercises we've been
doing in genius network here and uh
i just i just keep reminding myself i
don't know i don't have a 10-year goal
great things happen to me
it's a constant reminder and i
[Music]
i would i used to live it before this
awareness
i don't know like how many times would i
feel really down and low and anxiety
filled that i couldn't come up with a
new plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts
and now i'm probably living in great
things happen to me maybe
five percent of the time 10 of the time
which is a huge jump from half of one
percent but it's still not my default
mode yet
i'm still a believer in the plan guy
that's my ongoing challenge to myself
that's how i'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change
and the change starts with not just
questioning everything out there
questioning everything in here
questioning
what you believe to be true questioning
who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that
amazing things can happen
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to get
some incredible wayne dyer motivation
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there so let me just
kind of i'll number them and i'll go
through them
and i'll give you some examples of them
and
you decide whether they're to your
liking or whether they work or not
the first of these principles